welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars Episode nine deep
rise of Skywalker dropped new footage of
t23
showing Rey cosplay in its Darth Maul
and c-3po so high he feels like he's
walking on the sky called eye drops my
friend I'm gonna break down this new
footage frame by frame to explain what's
going on here and to find all the
miserable clues for how director JJ
Abrams might pull together all the major
elements from this sequel trilogy and
from this trilogy of trilogies to try to
give us a satisfying conclusion if
that's even possible we're warning in
case my predictions that have been too
accurate and let's get started okay
before we even get to the new rise of
Skywalker footage this special look
opens with famous imagery from past
films of the saga but I think there
actually might be a clue hidden in the
editing here right when some new audio
from Luke Skywalker plays over some
choice shots all we know
a thousand generations live in una but
this is your fight so presumably this is
Luke speaking as a kind of horse ghost
maybe an obi-wan style echo but to whom
is he speaking you could be talking to
Ray or to kylo both of whom he trained
and passed on key pieces of wisdom a
thousand generations do live on and Ray
through the ancient Jedi texts that she
took from each to scene in the final
shots of the last Jedi but also a
thousand generations of Sith master II
kind of live on through kylo as heir to
Darth Vader's memory Luke does say we
had passed on all we know collectively
referring to himself along with other
mentors including maybe Han or Yoda and
yes Luke's father and it's interesting
how the moment we hear Luke's say this
the montage transitions from a shot of
him as Jedi Master and returned the Jedi
to of all people Darth Maul igniting his
dual-wield lightsaber so they're almost
kind of like drawing a connection here
between Ray's training under Luke and
did the dark image of her that we see at
the end of this trailer wielding her own
ball style sabered this opening image
also emphasizes the touching of hands
kylo and Rey Leia and Rey han and kylo
ray and Finn that human connection that
complicates the characters inner drive
appears to be a key theme here and I
think it's significant that this montage
closes with Rey and her duel with kylo
and the force awakens with the two
lightsaber radiances flickering over her
face and reflecting from her eyes red
blue red blue kind of reflecting her tug
of war choice of paths and her
impressive resistance to seizure
inducing strobe lighting but why
speculate includes some old stuff when
there's new stuff to overanalyze so
onward
[Music]
okay the new footage shows the gang
reunited thin chewy rape Oh Dameron in
c-3po the Millennium Falcon is behind
them and they're overlooking the
celebration on the new desert planet
that's named Posada this appears to be
the same planet shot in a real-life
Jordan where array back flipped over the
TIE Interceptor in the teaser and a
location that the others have stolen the
merchant skiff this race of species is
called the Aki Aki and they're sentient
they wear multicolored robes and beaded
necklaces they're partying up with I
guess their version of Burning Man they
got kites chalk fireworks
maybe a wicker man style effigy back
there yeah I think 3p Oh might have
inhaled too much now it's not clear what
the group is seeking here other than a
bollard time but it's nice to see the
characters together again that's
supposed to you know split up across
casino planets and whatnot
and based on other footage the first
order will eventually catch up to them
here but next there's a shot of the late
Carrie Fisher as general Leia Organa and
some forest location that we saw her
embracing Rey in in the teaser JJ Abrams
said that they will use footage of
Fisher from the force awakens to
completely a story in this movie as
opposed to trying to recreate her using
VFX magic and at the moment it looks
pretty seamless on to the next section
[Music]
okay what's left of the resistance fleet
arrives and I love how they jump in to
the rhythm of John Williams melody they
appear to be jumping in within a
planet's atmosphere a very dangerous
move as we learned in the force awakens
but after Han Chewie and fin
successfully pulled off I suppose the
rest of the resistance figured it out
too among this ragtag fleet of our
x-wings y-wings
what appeared to be our z2 a wings and
finally some new beings after force
awakens last Jedi have only showed us
like pieces of the mark to be wing here
are some fully completed ones in action
and there's also this blockade runner
which some are speculated could actually
be the original tanta for from a new oak
not sure about that but if Abrams is
tying and callbacks from across the
series including the vessel that started
at all would be an awesome move now
presumably on one of these ships is Finn
joined by a new character resistance
fighter Jana played by Tommy a key and
some are saying that she could be the
daughter of Lando Calrissian but that
does not big a verb yet a key just joked
at Star Wars Celebration that Lando gets
around which we know he does in the
window outside their cockpit is a newbie
wing with a green glass firing past them
suggesting that they're in the midst of
some kind of dogfight which might
involve this monstrosity a massive fleet
of stardestroyers looks like at least
hundreds of them yeah we got to talk
about these because if you look closely
and if your best friends growing up
we're also the miniature Star Wars ships
on your desk and dresser you will notice
that these are actually imperial star
destroyers you know from the Empire the
thing that supposedly done they are is
di class with the X style bridge to be
specific in these disorders also have a
red stripe similar to the starter story
that we saw in a brief shot in the first
rises Skywalker teaser so perhaps the
first order is being supplanted by an
enormous imperial star destroyer fleet
that was somehow built in secret the
star wars aftermath novels detail what's
called Operation cinder kind of a bonito
down contingency plan orchestrated by
Palpatine in the event of his death it
was supposed to end it to coup and make
sure sell the ruins of that battle at
the top of the force awakens so I guess
maybe Palpatine had a second contingency
plan beyond operation center and that's
what we're seeing here I'll talk more
about what they started stories could be
up to in this movie in a bit and I want
to talk about three POS evil red eyes
but before I continue thanks to honey
for sponsoring this breakdown
everybody something online and then find
out that you could have gotten it for
less kind of sucks right it's worse than
like walking out of store right after
they put up a sign saying 50% off shirts
you wonder is this happening every time
I go shopping the shopkeeper laughs all
the time yeah luckily now I had honey
the free browser extension that saves
you time and money when shopping online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then like
magic it automatically applies the one
with the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout honey knows about every coupon
code sale or discount on over 20,000
sites like Amazon eBay Target gamestop
Best Buy nothing can hide from it and
you can just shop like normal honey
would do all the work for you in the
background to save you money and it
feels so good like sticking a boomerang
lightsabre catch despite an injury good
so I went on Newegg to buy some new
parts for my PC and with honey
I saved $110 59 cents I'm going to use
that to buy a mouse that is not covered
in pizza grease installation is super
easy just go to join honey calm slash
new rockstars couplets later there you
go and honey's for everyone because it
works for practically anything you buy
online and again downloading it is super
easy it only takes two clicks to install
and those who have already downloaded
honey using my link have already saved
an average of $43 and 19 cents so what
you waiting for there's really no reason
not to use honey it's free to use and
installs a new computer in just two
clicks get honey for free and join honey
calm slash new rock stars that's join
honey calm slash new rock stars okay
back to the trailer there's this shot of
Threepio with his rose tinted eyepieces
so these red eyes could be inspired by
triple zero the red eyed protocol droid
from the Darth Vader comic so we'll
combine dr. Aphra in accompanying bt1 on
a number of dark and evil doings another
possible influence could have come from
c-3po as manufacture who also produced a
variant known as c-3po a protocol droid
with a red sensor
reprogrammed to serve Sasson functions
but you know red eyes don't always mean
evil just most of the time it's also
possible the three because red eyes as a
result of some kind of diagnostic
function in fact one theory for Threepio
in this movie involves them scanning his
memories number three Pio had his memory
wiped
after Revenge of the Sith but his
one-shot storyline did reveal that some
memory fragments remain deeply implanted
inside him and maybe it's those memories
that Poe in the others are hoping to
unlock for a way to defeat this new
threat from
palpatine because throughout this entire
saga only two droids were there to
witness all of it and before we move on
there's a shot of a huge red blast
leveling a planet's terrain now display
that looks like kg me this is a new icy
mountainous planet that is connected to
Zoe Blissett scary Russell's character
is a criminal and old friend of Poe's
now there's also some speculation that
the new superweapon of this movie as
opposed to the planet-destroying death
stars or star killer base instead the
super weapon could be a fleet of
stardestroyers that devastate a planet's
surface like breaking up the crust layer
thereby killing all life on it but not
the simple Swift act of like popping a
densely packed core of matter this
surface destruction could explain why
this blast hits the surface with the
initial shock wave that then follows it
with a second impact blast kind of like
the terra formation surface destruction
that we saw in movies like Man of Steel
let's move on
ok this next clip shows ray training
slicing tree trunks tossing our light
saber perhaps frustrated at that
marksmen and remote droids are annoying
as hell it's similar to the one that
Luke first trained with on the Falcon
and a new hope now remember this light
saber handles split in the last Jedi so
ray must have repaired it that might be
why she has that red cloth around her
palm maybe the Kyber crystal in sight it
is radiating out of it no kind of leak
from the fissure from the repaired
handle causing Ray's palm to get burned
and you'll notice that when Ray catches
the lightsaber she's also holding this
limb is a bo staff like maybe she's
finding that combat with a sword like
weapon is incompatible with her full
range of skills which is why her dream
weapon would be a dual wield bo staff
inspired lightsaber this is all set a
forest location that looks a bit similar
to the location where Leia appeared and
I'm wondering if this could be Endor we
do know that the ruins of the second
death star appear in this film which
could be on the nearby forest moon from
returned the Jedi perhaps raise battle
with kylo Ren will lead to a defeat
wound on her hand causing her to train
in the nearby forest and blow off steam
and wondered I only had a double sided
weapon to match my agility I could beat
him to force ghost Leia to explain how
that kind of power is a dangerous path
then there's a shot of kylo Ren igniting
his lightsaber as he walks from his tie
interceptor and I think this is the one
that Rey left over and personna but this
is a new ship for kylo from his tie
silencer in the last Jedi based on these
lightning strikes I'm thinking this
could also be Cugini
which would be the planet surface
wrecked by the fleet of stardestroyers
might explain the pictures on the ground
there as it's walking over them kylo
drags his saber in the snow kicking it
up and ruins this name very nicely into
the ocean spray of the next shot which
is an epic duel between kylo and rey on
this submerged wreckage which we know
are pieces of the Death Star but notice
that gun turret to the left
so not only are these chunks of Death
Star this could be a wall of the Death
Star trench like they could be trying to
echo the famous trench run along the
first step star trench in a new hope
essentially this younger generation is
battling over the literal graves of the
older generations famous battles yeah
symbolism as the nerd will scream when
this scene comes up on opening night in
the cinema under the next clip yes it's
in
okay so Ian McDiarmid is returning as
Emperor Palpatine aka Darth Sidious his
voice croaks yes
so perhaps Palpatine has returned to
some kind of sit ghostly presence there
actually is precedence of the Sith
haunting enchanted objects after their
deaths also in the comics Palpatine has
cloned himself and of course there's
always the legend of death Plagueis the
wise the Sith who learned how to
overcome death really there are any
number of ways Palpatine could come back
but again we're left wondering to whom
Palpatine is speaking whose journey is
nearing its end is it Rey or kylo or
could it be communion with the ghost of
Luke because if you listen super closely
to this moment the audio mixer snuck in
a fascinating cacophony of noises yes
so most distinctly you can hear the
breath of Darth Vader's mask now does
this mean Vader will return in some form
in the rise of Skywalker well there was
a rumored scene that would feature kylo
witnessing the moment of Bader's first
machine-assisted breath from Revenge of
the Sith so maybe this sound is
connected to that but also mixed in here
is a clash of thunder and oddly some
soft musical chimes which almost sound
like John Williams orchestration after
his opening fanfare in every movie but
there's even more to talk about in this
money shot dark Rey holding a dual wield
red lightsaber similar to Darth Maul's
but this one lights up like a tuning
fork then opens up on a hinge to walk
into a bo staff style weapon the design
is actually kind of similar to the
sabers used by the temple guards with
Kanan and the animated series as well as
the dual wield saber used by pong Krell
but notice that the red blades are
firing and unstable which wasn't the
case with Darth Maul sabers this is more
like kylos weapon kylos braid is
unstable because it's powered by a
cracked Kyber crystal reflecting his
instability so perhaps Rey's weapon here
is meant to reflect that same kind of
brokenness it's also worth noting raised
left hand in a shot the one that we
previously saw covered with a red cloth
now there's some kind of black band
across her knuckles
maybe that cloth was a bandage from her
fingers being partially or fully severed
either from the unstable repaired blue
lightsaber I mentioned before maybe the
battle with kylo but Daisy Ridley has
said that she was surprised that they
included this shot in the trailer and
it's possible that it's not a literal
depiction of events in the movie but
rather a dream or vision hallucination
in fact these star wars common
description of this footage originally
described this moment as the vision of a
Rey before updating it to change to the
sight of Rey but before we go too deep
down this rabbit hole of speculation
that Rey is being possessed by Palpatine
or switched fully to the darkside let's
remember that in the Empire Strikes Back
Luke Skywalker experienced a vision of
himself inside Darth Vader's mask on
Dagobah and remember that trailer for
rogue 1 ended with a similar implication
that gen or so would go dark what will
you become
yeah so similarly this could be a Vision
Quest moment for Rey tempted to acquire
more power with a weapon that would suit
her skill set to vanquish her enemies
but ultimately keeping the wisdom of the
bed
angels of her nature angels named Carrie
Fisher but there is one more sound
design Easter egg here notice the sound
of raised blades we hear - hums now if
you loop that back for a third hum you
get
so those hums are actually in the note
of G GG G and those G's are actually the
first notes of Darth Vader's Imperial
March if I sound crazy consider that
Star Wars movies actually mix in subtle
light motifs to John Williams score all
the time
rogue ones awesome Vader Death March was
scored with a slowdown choral modulation
of the Imperial March they can only
notice by speeding it up so maybe this
moment is designed to lead us to wonder
who the successor of the Sith truly will
be the Skywalker air or the angry or
finding and let's overanalyze the hell
out of the music in the final clip
[Music]
okay after a title card set to the
dramatic rendition of Williams force
theme the final notes are a sad take on
Ray's theme which is composed for the
force awakens so this trailer ends in a
kind of mournful echo of Ray's humble
beginnings what happened to her a little
junk scavenger from jakku well she
killed up but ton of people on the
supremacy and now she's a different
person do you think Ray has truly turned
evil and how do you think Palpatine has
returned comment down below with your
thoughts and theories follow me on
twitter and instagram @ e a boss its
subscribed in the rock stars more
breakdown some theories about everything
star wars it if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe to our star wars
podcast feed called WikiLeaks for early
access to audio versions of all this
stuff and for some upcoming podcast
exclusive content thank you for joining
me if you haven't liked this video
already doing
[Music]